I definitely don't always win but I'm  always playing to win you know like I  want to win I want my companies to be  the biggest I want to win it's my game  like what are we doing here it's a game  I want to win I don't think that's a bad  thing I'm I'm fiercely competitive  however I do think that for me at least  I don't think my winning comes out of  anybody else's pocket so for me it's  like I want to win but I want everybody  else to win too in the agency land when  we pitch a new piece of business if  another agency wins all right like we  lost like we didn't tell the client what  they wanted here they went somewhere  else it's not like I hate Johnny or  Ricky I'm surprised that people don't  know how to balance trying to be  successful and enjoying their process  and loving their game and being  competitive with also being okay for  rooting for everyone else including  people that are direct competitors